it's time for dinner dinner
back in my day people talk face to face
faster ass ass to ass
all right joe do the intro all right
hello my bass boosted brother and
welcome to another episode of trash
taste oh that was that wasn't sad that
was an old school joey intro
you actually are bringing back the
alliteration
for one episode even though that was not
alliterated at all sounded so depressed
though huh you sounded so depressed okay
moving on let's do this again mood on
bass boost me when i say this welcome
back
so welcome back to another episode of
trash taste podcast uh i am bass boosted
boy number one with basis boy number two
and three hello hi hi
my permanent life is basically yeah
that's what i was i was going to say
that's just like your voices
never got turned off you just got left
on put up the treble on connor like
really high
uh how you boys
how are you feeling i i feel like you
need a therapist joey because i feel
like you've uh you've almost been
cancelled again on twitter for saying
more or hotter it's gonna be the weekly
thing or just like review like possible
cancellation of the week cancellation
and today on the chopping block today i
just i just found it funny that uh after
all this time you actually go out your
way to watch anime again i think one
time i tweet about anime
joey
joey has the first anime take in like
what like six months and then uh what
was the take
[Music]
remind me okay
okay so
let me let me bring you up to speed
right because this is a multi-layered
okay okay this is like a multi-layered
meme multimedia angles to cancel okay so
it started off the the layer first
starts at the caisson episode right that
which is of us recording it just went up
right and yeah you know thankfully a lot
of people loved it it was a great
episode right yeah but on one segment of
that show and there's a highlight clip
of it uh is where we talk about the jews
of kaisen anime yeah i think it's
because we were talking to caisson about
like what anime she's watched recently
or something like that
weeks ago for us um and so i was like
you know
after me finally having seen it
you know a while back i was like oh i'll
uh you know i think this might be a
perfect time right now since we're
already talking about the anime to you
know kind of go into it a little bit
talk about it right give our thoughts on
it how hot takes if you will yeah uh and
my hot take of dudes to kaisen was me
saying i thought it was okay
and uh and then followed by i just
preferred demon slayer yeah that's a
show right and there's a [ __ ] high
likelihood i mean you are a clown for
that opinion i gotta admit
maybe i don't know a new season though
it's kind of tough right right maybe
yeah yeah yeah okay at the time of
recording that was clown take but now
okay maybe not i mean it was a clown
take those because it's literally
because in the clip i'm pretty sure i
said something along the lines of jesus
kaisen had everything that you know i
thought i was going to like but for some
reason whatever it was i can't even give
like a like a proper
viable like you know
reason for it to just say that for some
reason it just didn't really click in my
head yeah never did i say that the show
was like mid or that the show was bad in
any way i just said i thought it was
okay yeah yeah twitter
went
ballistic over that
there were like a couple of how how
ballistic we talking i mean after a few
angry people or like i mean yeah i mean
you know twitter does what's what it
does best right it gets [ __ ] you know
just overblows everything out of
proportion but like i even had a couple
of people tweeting at me like videos
from like small and youtubers being like
joe you're getting canceled and i'm like
oh god what now
is it for something i liked on twitter i
don't know and i went to look at it and
it was like joey's hottest take on jews
and kyson and on the thumbnail it just
says he thought it was okay and i was
like oh my god i can't even call a show
okay anymore without being cancelled
like what the [ __ ] is this and then so
that's layer one yeah okay okay layer
two
is when i started watching demon slave
season two recently right and i made a
tweet you know first tweet in six months
about anime where i say something along
the lines of uh i started watching
season two of demon slayer happy to say
zany is still the worst character in the
show
all the zenitsu fans went ballistic
as they do of course they do as they do
you know calling your best boy
they stand up wearing those diapers yeah
exactly yes
and then and then but
but then some people took it back to
that you know recent [ __ ] clip of me
talking about jesus christ and saying
that demons better than jesus christ and
they had the audacity to be like oh now
he's backpedaling
now he's backpedaling now he said he he
hyped up demon slayer so much even
comparing it to jesus christ and saying
it was better than jesus christ and now
he's saying that oh it's it's the demon
slayer is not a good show which i never
said
mind you i just said zany to [ __ ]
sucks because he does
right he does and it's like and it's
like if anything i'm [ __ ] enjoying
season two right now season two has been
great i feel season two's like kind of
brought back the hype for demon slayer
for a long time yeah right i wasn't that
hype but season two is made yeah
definitely like the like the movie you
know as moon oh god is this going to be
another [ __ ] hot take as as okay as i
thought the movie was
no okay okay i'll agree with you i
thought the season two has blown the
movie yeah out of the way you know i'm
gonna say because like i recently just
finished my anime with the you know man
made of the year video i feel like anime
has gotten uh so much better now that
just saying something is okay
is now detrimental to the anime right
right it's not even bad anymore yeah
like calling something mid is an insult
and someone calling something okay is an
insult i feel like it's a copy pastor
now where everyone is like attack on
titan is mid it's basically a copyright
right like everyone everyone that keeps
saying that exact phrase yeah not no
elaboration no attack on titan is mid
because it's such easy bait yeah it
it's literally fake but everyone does
but the thing is i didn't even say jesus
and kaisen is okay for bait i just
legitimately think it's just okay
i really like jesus
yeah and and that's fine right like
there were parts of jesus christ i
really enjoyed but i don't i personally
didn't enjoy it as much as other people
or as i thought i was going to well do
you feel like saying something is okay
or mid is even more of an insult than
saying something is bad nowadays because
i feel like maybe i i feel like i've
just like at least in like discussing
shows or anime or whatever or manga i
feel like you you don't see as many
people just saying something is straight
up bad anymore right people just say oh
it's mid it's just mid yes okay look
like
i get the word mid mid is insulting yeah
yeah he's admitted so little effort to
articulate how you feel about a show you
can't even you can't even like
get the energy to even describe what you
don't like about it
i feel like the the word average when
talking about a show there's like
there's like a a contention between like
okay being like you know taking more in
a positive way yeah and then mid being
taken in like a negative way right but
they both mean the same thing
technically speaking mid is just short
for middle
which is okay
yeah neither good or bad just okay right
but like i feel now people take the word
okay and put like a negative spin on it
which yeah
it's like if uh
let's say uh
you had a wedding right yeah and you're
like mom did you like the wedding she's
like it was okay
i would be annoyed i would be like what
do you mean my wedding was just uh i
invited you i put on a spread right but
i feel okay but i feel it's free but i
feel but i feel it's kind of on you to
compare your own wedding to jesus
how strongly i feel how about my best
friend okay yeah i was like how did we
get from jiu-jitsu guys into a wedding
because i'm just thinking like let's
just say you are you you put your heart
and soul out of the sub that you like
yeah yeah okay
i'm gonna go to sydney today and be like
sydney i know we're getting married this
year but like justin tyson right i mean
it's it's kind of it's kind of more
important
i pulled my heart into jiu-jitsu i said
more than i did the wedding i hope so
you know there's someone out there that
would say that i hope somebody asked me
how was god's wedding because i know i
know what i'm going to say
i already know what i'm going to say i
prefer jesus
yeah i don't know just uh so so my uh my
advice to all of you who perhaps want to
share your opinion about anime don't use
the word okay from now on it can get you
canceled no it's just because it's
because of who we are right it's cause
like now we we have this little show we
do this little thing this little show
show you know and uh it's all it's i
think there's a lot more eyes on us yeah
so people
want to want to get angry uh
you know because a lot of the times
people are getting annoyed at this stuff
aren't the people who like actually like
watch trash taste yeah
outside of trash taste maybe have like
some followers who've watched trash
taste maybe say some of the clips or
whatever and they're like you won't
believe what they these these guys who i
don't already watch or engage with said
like
they don't know how we we behave or how
we like go towards the topic or how we
tackle it it's just like he just said
this thing i disagree with it i'm gonna
get angry what's what's like really
weird especially about my jewish kaisen
hot take hot take is the fact that i
called usually kyson okay
months ago on my own channel yeah no one
[ __ ] batted a knife
right it's weird because like i feel
we've got to that point now where
uh like not super small twitter accounts
but some twitter accounts with some
decent followings will be like
this clown take on trash taste
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i think that's
also kind of cool i'm like oh that's
awesome that people feel like i'm
they're big like we're big enough where
they can just openly like criticize us i
mean yeah like go ahead
it is it is humbling to think that my
offhand comment about an anime has like
stirred up this much controversy
it's kind of cool but at the same time
it's like can you not cancel me for
saying that a show is okay i could at
least sleep over here if someone gets
angry
sleeping over and i just think it's a
little like you know i'm glad i you know
imagine uh
back four or five years ago if i'd said
the same [ __ ] no no one would give up oh
okay i think like i'm glad that people
care sometimes it's annoying it's a
little too much i love it thank you for
caring about my dumb opinion about a
show i don't care about joe's opinion
i don't even care about my opinion i
just said it well i i think the argument
is that you know we are you know
creators who have a platform and an
influence i mean that's why they call
people like us influencers right
you know i mean i'm i have the i got
like that evil voice going for me so i
feel like it works yeah someone calls me
an influencer yeah it's just like the
one thing i don't like about that word
is that it can apply to
so many things you know like a cult
leader is technically an influencer as
well those are the influences yeah
they're the og influencers right like i
don't know if i want to be bunched up in
those games i'm kidding by the way i i i
actually like the word i like to think
that i make something that's somewhat
entertaining and good yeah i'm just a
dude on the internet no no yeah
yeah i'm with a bunch of hot days yeah i
mean i mean i i feel like you know i i
get it to a certain extent where we do
have to you know be careful about some
of the stuff we say right because we you
know there are some topics that i feel
we do have to like navigate it's very
you know very careful of course because
there are other creators out there who
do have a platform and uh their word
they say [ __ ] and uh their words have a
tangible effect on the real world and
the community they talk to but at the
same time
there there are some things that i just
like i it blows my mind that people care
this much about right right
and you know like one of one of the
biggest things that i don't understand
is you know people take this people will
people will take this you know one
minute two minute clip from trash taste
or from one of our streams because it's
happened to me a bunch of times right uh
where
where i will see this clip being
circulated where it's like a one or two
minute clip from the podcast on my
stream that's like not scripted it's
just in a conversation that's most of
the time doesn't even have anything to
do with the take that i'm saying in that
one clip because it's like one or two
minutes yeah yeah yeah and they will
take this clip and then spin it to like
a whole new level of
like you've planned it all out yeah yeah
yeah like it's a [ __ ] mastermind move
yeah yeah and like and like i think of
this in context right and i'm thinking i
don't think people who watch our show or
people who are super fans of the show is
going to be influenced by a one minute
clip of us talking about this one
subject right that most of the time
doesn't even have to do with the overall
conversation it's just like it's just
most of the time just like an offhand
comment or something yeah i don't think
that's gonna [ __ ] influence anybody
yeah like on that on that segment where
joe you you spoke about jesus christ and
i was like no you're you're a clown
right it's good you know how if you're a
viewer it's like how can you argue that
then
you're being influenced to be like juju
kaisen is mitt or okay because like
there's an active argument going on
where you're saying no it's it's not
you're wrong so like what do you think
well right you take away from that it's
not oh i'm going to think to carson's
mid even if you're like a super fan
right it's so stupid
that's what i think i like about you
know those kinds of discussions on the
show especially when like you know to to
or all of us are like arguing against
each other right is that like it gives
so many different points of views where
like it's up to the viewers now who you
want to agree with right and it's like
it's not so much it's not so much me
saying hey because i think jesus christ
is okay you should also think that way i
mean if you want to think that way
that's on you right but it's not like
i'm coming out here you know [ __ ]
starting a demo of being like everybody
stand up and rise jesus christ is just
okay
yeah i just don't get it like you know
it's fine to be influenced by certain
things but at the same time
it's like
it's just a sharp well i think it's a
good problem to have in our job of
course of course people would uh
spend a lot lot many years trying to get
to the point where we're very fortunate
where you know people watch trash tanks
and people care i feel very lucky that
people want to get angry about small
things like jokes yeah that's fine is it
is it you know is it a contention for
cancellation though i'm not sure about
that yeah
i don't know it goes back to like online
hate day as well i mean i've gone to the
point now where it doesn't really bother
me that much at all really it's got it's
interesting i don't i think this is just
because i've been online for so long now
where now i'm just kind of like
at equilibrium with it i'm like i don't
know yeah it's it's i wouldn't even say
it's because like i'm okay with it now
or i'm like numb to it i guess it's like
i think i think jessica negri said it
best
uh she said when someone asked her about
like how do you deal with like internet
hate yeah like how do you get over it
yeah and she said like you never get
over it it still hurts but you just
learn to live with it like to to me to
me because we have talked about this a
few times but to me like you know
without getting to like the online hate
thing the thing that like the one thing
that annoys me then just people actually
actually just like hating on me and
hating on my content for example is just
when when people are like trying to put
words in my mouth yeah to be like to be
like
gant said this or god said this and that
means x you know or that means x y z and
that that to me there's nothing that
wants to make me reply more than people
who are spreading this idea that i you
know maybe others
it is right it is it is
because at that point like it's i've
seen some like instances where like you
know i say one thing right and then it
just like spirals out into this like
insane story about like how i [ __ ]
killed a child or some [ __ ] right like
it's like
it's like that level of like how did you
take this one little piece of
information and spin it in a way that
it's just couldn't be further from the
trip like you're basically writing a fan
fiction at that point
and it's like it's like what and then
there are people who look at that and be
like oh yeah that's that sounds like
something he'd say i'm like what
i've been thinking about
because i i swear to god i don't know if
they like i i don't know if the anime
community was always like this because
like to me there are there are some
there are some topics that i always like
used to love arguing about you know
because
i felt like to me you know there are
some things where you really have to be
careful about what you say in terms like
religion politics and stuff like that
you know that's the reason why we never
talk about that we've spoken about a
little bit yeah yeah yeah and uh we
never actually try and avoid it
sometimes you just want to have like a
fun argument on someone where you can
you can just [ __ ] on your opinion and
you don't have to worry about about it
because you know that at the end of the
day the topic doesn't really matter that
much right and to me like as as an anime
fan anime was always one of those topics
for me until like quite recently and i
don't know if that's just my perception
because like another topic i would say
is you can easily argue with anyone
about is food everyone loves arguing
about food we do it all the [ __ ] time
because it's fun and it's fun because
people understand that people have
different tastes and opinions right and
to me like anime was always
at that same level as i can easily argue
about anyone with anime and not have to
worry about you know hurting their
feelings too much because i i just
assume we all everyone in our community
has like an understanding that dude you
can have your own taste you can have
your own it's mutual agreement that at
the end of the day even if this one
random internet person doesn't think
that your favorite show is as good as it
is it's like well that's not going to
deter me from the fact that i still like
the show it's just changed just because
of the scale of trash taste right it's
like you know there's nothing like this
back in the day you know back in podtaku
what was the like average viewer count
like i think our most viewed podcast
ever was like 100k
which you know back then was crazy
crazy yeah you know obviously the scale
is completely different now yeah anime
has also been somewhat more democratized
in a way like democratized
yeah definitely more it's more available
to more eyes it's a lot easier to get a
hold of yeah
you know and discourse about it is way
more open and people are way more open
to talk about it so i think that's why
it's some of the reasons why
so the problem is it's getting popular
well essentially i mean
you could almost say it's becoming
mainstream insider because i i was i i
always had this like image that
the anime community felt like it was
about like 10 5 10 years behind what we
saw with the gaming community right
because it felt like maybe gaming the
gaming industry also had this shift
where games used to be just this fun
things you numb your numb your brain out
to didn't really matter that much you
know you could just have your fun with
it and then now games mean like
games are a big business
and it's the same yeah i know that some
people gave zelda breath the while like
a seven out of ten when it came out and
they got controversy for that
because they didn't give it a nine or
ten or something so basically they got
canceled for saying breath of the wild
was just okay
we've had the same thing it's the same
thing again isn't it incredible how one
word can completely change everything
like there's such a huge difference in
like insinuation between calling
something good and calling something
just good it could be the attitude
towards it as well you know sometimes i
think uh
sometimes
i can understand sometimes the way you
talk about anime could definitely like
you're so like you're like yeah it's mid
and i can understand why why you piss
people off because you sound like you
won't even entertain the conversation
you're like i [ __ ] hate the fact that
you even brought this up to me it was
mid stop talking to me about it so i can
understand why sometimes people can get
annoyed by that yeah because they're
like i wish joey just even listened to
me it's like me trying to get approval
from my parents it's like i wish my
parents just gave it a chance it's like
no no it's like you're like [ __ ] you're
like it's mid you know i think maybe
that's what annoys people i yeah and and
look i can completely get that as well
and that is my bad to be fair but at the
same time it's like you know sometimes i
don't even bother engaging in these
conversations because i already know how
it's going to end i i i i get you i get
you because it's just it's just happened
so many times that i've done this for
almost nine years yeah i know how a
conversation like this is gonna end i i
mean i've known you for ages so yeah i
could say i know how you are with these
conversations yeah i could say i could
give out all these like well thought out
constructed arguments about why i think
the show was okay and people will be
like but but but but but but i don't
agree with that and i'm like oh my gosh
what more can i say so what you're
saying is if trash day started six years
ago you might have got more enthusiastic
debate oh yeah dude
this would actually be an anime podcast
no no no no i don't
you know going back to the hate thing
what's uh because you always get asked
right by new creators or something or
anyone uh how do you deal with online
hey what's what's the advice that you
give someone because i've been i've been
mulling this over a lot recently because
i think my opinion on it has changed
quite a lot
since the last time we talked about this
i think so i think i had this like
perspective shift uh recently and i
don't know why um but i was like
i the whole thing of uh living with it
and stuff is totally valid advice and i
think that's also good but i don't know
what happened but now i look at it and i
don't really care at all when i see it
because to me in my head i they're never
angry at like me as a individual person
when i read that it's like they're angry
at like what they think is me
right right they're not angry at if they
sat with me and spoke with me they
probably wouldn't feel that way right
but yeah but they angry at the idea of
me and and more often than not it's like
they were never going to give me a
chance anyway because i'm just i must be
a personality they don't like yeah see
but like i feel that way of thinking
about things is only
was has only been constructed because
you've been doing this for so long yeah
definitely and like i don't think there
are very very few people who can come
right into this industry from the jump
and have this like enough
self-confidence in themselves and their
content and their self-image on the
internet to be like well that's not
about me that's just about their image
of me right and i feel like you know
especially when i started off like i
didn't have that kind of [ __ ]
confidence right now sure a lot of
people didn't where you know so like
anything like the moment your name gets
mentioned in something and even if it's
not exactly the most like detrimental
thing you know jab at your personality
or whatever
i think people just not used to this and
having this like random amount of people
coming up to you and being like by the
way your kind of [ __ ] you know is a
thing that we're not really used to
right because the human wasn't involved
how many people just walk down the
street and have a random person be like
excuse me you're [ __ ] like no
it doesn't happen right but on the
internet that's normal and i think new
york yeah
that said like people on the internet
have internet have gotten way too used
to saying things not getting punched in
the face for it yeah they're like
absolutely there's no repercussions so
it's like you know they they just think
oh it's just free range to say the [ __ ]
i want
and i was about to say like you know and
yes in a sense it is kind of free range
to say whatever you want but you know
with the repercussions you know like you
can say whatever you want as long as
you're willing to pay for the
repercussions if they come back to you
right and they're very well might you
know yeah because like i actually had to
like train my mom up for this like
recently because she she's not getting
hate but sometimes she goes through like
the trash taste videos and like you know
some of the streams and like the
comments and she like finds these
comments and like
god i want to reply right now i want to
tell them that they're wrong i'm like
mom do not do that
do not do that that's even worse
my mom does like because my mom my mum
reads like so many comments and like she
does she doesn't understand how to like
how to deal with online hate especially
to like her own son so she's just she's
just like well sometimes she'll just
like send me send me like a bunch of
[ __ ] comments being like look at all
these people saying wrong information
about you i want to reply is that i
wanted like a southeast asian thing
because aki's mom does exactly the same
where she had to be like mom stop
sending me this [ __ ] stop replying to
this [ __ ] just leave it i'm fine
i literally have to explain to her it's
like it's like if a school bully said
something to me and and you come up to
the school bully in front of everyone
and be like don't talk don't talk about
my son like that
i'm like mom this looks even worse than
even if i reply to her personally okay
oh no
no
how did she take it how did she take it
i mean she i mean i told her not to do
it i'm just like don't you just just
don't read it mom just i i understand
what you're going through everyone who's
a content creator goes through this at
the beginning but you just gotta
understand that people are gonna get
just gonna stay stuff and actually
couldn't be more the opposite of that
like my parents would be like oh you
know my dad would be like oh yeah some
people were saying [ __ ] about your last
video and i'm like really he's like yeah
but they're all dicks don't worry about
it
bro i'm sweating for the day where i'm
just waiting for the day where i wake up
on twitter one day and then i wake up to
like a screenshot that's been spread
viral about my mum replying to like one
of my haters comments be like yo have
you seen what god's mom said to this
person and i'm like for [ __ ] that's fine
i just want to say tweet i just want to
see it from your mom being like what the
[ __ ] did you say to you little [ __ ]
now
i'll have you know i have 300 confirmed
kills
[Laughter]
oh my god i love that
i i think we should uh we need some
comments from your mom i think that's
yeah definitely i think that'd be good
we should have a segment we read out
your mum's required comments
have your parents ever like look through
your comments or look through your
videos to see what people are saying
about you i think so i think my mom one
time was like really sad about it she
was like why are they saying mean things
there's on this one thing about you
right she's like don't worry about it
it's not a big deal she's like it's so
cute though yeah she was way more upset
about it than i was yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] you know uh
obviously because it's not normal to see
people bad-mouth your
son yeah of course it's not a normal
thing you get to experience yeah it's
quite a visceral emotion i mean i i'd be
lying if i said if if my kid was in that
situation i wouldn't do the same thing
right oh yeah i'd probably want to punch
punch someone yeah i'd be like don't
worry you made my kids they're just
dicks yeah yeah like honestly i i kind
of get it i'm the same i guess because i
i feel like more anger when i see you
know people's [ __ ] talking sydney
when i when i see people oh yeah it's
the same like
if i see one person's [ __ ] talking when
i'm bros i'm just like [ __ ] that yeah
yeah i wanna i wanna [ __ ] call them
out now and i guess like if in that vein
like the one i think the one thing i
hate more than people taking my [ __ ] out
of context right and trying to cancel me
for something completely not related is
when they just like drag my friend into
it and especially people who like don't
matter at all i'm like okay you can say
[ __ ] about me right like i'll take care
of her that'll be my problem yeah but
don't drag people who have nothing to do
with this [ __ ] yeah don't drag in my
girlfriend or my friends or like my
[ __ ] mom or anything like this got
nothing to do with them if you hate my
opinion just [ __ ] talk me i'll i'll deal
with it i'll cry into my own pillow but
i won't i don't i don't want people [ __ ]
talking to other people that's like the
one thing i hate don't do that you're a
dick if you do that
you're a dick if you do that this
episode is sponsored by honey the easy
way to save when shopping on your iphone
or computer guys how do you feel about
shopping online i enjoy it it's very uh
handy shop in person
you do it quite often right of course i
mean of course well weebs we don't leave
the house
do you want to save more money hell yeah
of course thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past so really save money that's
easily honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones it finds to
your car imagine you're shopping on one
of your favorite sites when you get to
the checkout the honey button appears
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds for honey to
search for the coupon to confine for
this site and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop boys
this the valentine's weekend as we're
recording this what did you say on well
i cheaped out and i bought some flowers
for sydney don't tell her but i saved so
much money thanks to honey how much did
you say god i saved a whole 15 bucks on
flowers on flowers they're basically
giving it two for free i know damn don't
tell sydney but did you know gentlemen
that honey doesn't just work on desktop
it works on your iphone too just
activate it on safari on your phone and
you can save on the go on the go on the
go if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting boys as well i
never recommend something i don't use so
get honey free today at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey.com trash
taste back to the episode this is our
like what is it like
uh quarterly youtube
uh twitch uh rant podcast
yeah i mean yeah i mean i i i you know i
know a lot of people might not empathize
with us because we do talk about it you
know a lot and i i don't know if for an
audience is tiring ever but i kind of
feel like we therapy shows
otherwise we're just going to have like
half this like emotion in us and we just
every time every so often i just need to
let it out of course i just need i just
need to let out i feel like for content
creators uh it's healthy you know and
it's like to me being able to talk to
other content creators about it it's a
healthy way to get
all of this like toxicity out of
yourself and just you know get on with
your life yeah you know i think uh
before trash takes definitely we need to
talk to another content creator every
now and then just rent yeah just need it
because it's better to rent to another
content creator than do it on a video or
a stream oh yeah definitely okay all
right i got a i got a question have you
guys ever like tried to explain when
you're like going through some
controversy or something's going on and
you have to try and explain it to
someone who just does not understand
youtube and it's just really involved oh
yeah it doesn't work
i'm just like don't worry about it it's
a little annoying right now
yeah yeah no like no hate against anyone
we explain this to because to to their
credit they tried their hardest to
understand what's going on but like i
don't get it
yeah i i remember i had to like pretty
early on in my career when like you know
i was getting that like you know the
first initial wave of like you know
you're you're you're notable enough in
the community now where people outside
of your community will find you yeah
corpse party was made something like
that
but like you know when you when you
first start to get that first wave and
you're like oh [ __ ] i don't know who to
talk about i don't know i'm getting
cancelled blah blah blah even though it
was like barely nothing right i remember
i was talking to one of my schoolmates
about it being like yeah so like
these bunch of people like coming into
my you know comment section saying that
i suck and blah blah blah i remember one
of them was just straight up like just
tell them the [ __ ] off
i was like
yeah
thought about that
not an option unfortunately when you're
it's with one of me and uh many others
you know who i'm up against not not
really that easy is it yeah because it
really was that easy if if only because
like i remember like every time i've
tried to explain something that's been
going on in this in like the youtube's
field some controversy you're just like
oh okay so um this person said this and
it piss is pissing a bunch of people off
like holy [ __ ] twitter is getting angry
and then you talk to the person they're
like uh why why people getting angry and
you're just like
um i said this anime was bad
so this person said this anime was bad
and these group of people got pissed off
about it and then they go so why they
pissed why why were they pissed off
about it and then you keep going layers
and layers deep until you get to a point
where you they just forget what the
original like people are getting angry
for now or to the point where you like
the more arguments come through and the
more layers down it goes you just start
to realize wait it's not a problem
there's no problem to begin with i'm
just making it yeah i mean like i
remember back in the day where drama
could be addressed with like one just
one short twit longer and now it's got
to a point where you need like a four
hour breakdown to like to like
understand like the full depth of some
of this drama and i like i don't know
when that shift happened when it was
just like okay now now you need a
[ __ ] thesis like it's a full-on
dissertation to like to like break down
the like a play-by-play of like the
entire months
the entire month leading up to this one
tweet except instead of one professor
like marking it down it's the entirety
of the internet being like but did you
use correct citations for it
no marx do we have the receipts do you
have the receipts
yeah it's uh it's it's crazy it's crazy
how uh
how especially that side of this the
internet has evolved especially like i
think i think drama culture is kind of a
thing now where oh it's definitely well
i i see some content creators who you
know start off
start off doing their own thing and then
i don't know how or why but
a lot of a lot of people i've seen have
just slowly shifted into just like
drama channels you know maybe
intentionally maybe not intentionally
but it seems like every other upload
seems to be talking about some kind of
drama or some kind of consciousness
that's going on
it's very good for business though oh
definitely it's
one of those things where if you're in
drama that isn't really drama like it's
something you you let's say yeah like
you said you have a bad take on anime or
something right those kind of
drama are just generally just
good for you
because there's no real downside because
nobody nobody who actually watches you
gives a [ __ ] that you said a show is bad
i you know like when i said 86 i didn't
like 86 right there's a lot of people
mad about that yeah but i doubt there
was many people who are like i can't
watch trash taste or connor ever again
because he said my favorite show is bad
yeah right but maybe other people who
are like maybe some people who are
watching you or some people outside of
it see this drama and think this is
really [ __ ] stupid uh i might go
check them out or i'm more familiar with
their name through this drama because
because drama has a really good way of
i feel like a click on a drama video is
like much more engaging than a normal
class oh yeah so when you get like a a
million views on a drama video yeah the
million views on that drama video and
maybe that's a generic gaming video
they're not equal like the drama
engagement and how much people are
invested is so much more yeah and
especially if it's something that paints
you in a good light or paints you in a
way that makes it look like you didn't
really do anything yeah then it's just
it's great for you because that now
you're just gonna get people who are
more invested in you people who think
that you've been done wrong and then
they're gonna support you more yeah so
when these people do this [ __ ] and they
try and drag you in the drama this is
why a lot of
a lot of big twitch streamers get into
this kind of drama very often because it
is really good for solid solidifying
your bass viewership they they want to
support you they will they will help you
and then people who see it and think oh
they weren't really in the wrong they
might come and check you out and feel a
bit more strongly about you because they
want to support you because they feel
like this is some [ __ ] that was done
to you i feel like drama videos like
especially in like multiple successions
right on the same drama like every day
it's like it's almost like the world's
most engaging let's play yeah you know
in a sense where it's like you know
you're more likely if you're really into
like a drama video you're more likely to
come back to that part than
i think i think it's just the modern day
reality tv show oh definitely because
like here's the thing do you think do
you think people actually care about
drama do you think people like no only
when it's like you know clearly like
there is a wrong person who did a [ __ ]
thing right but like like 90 percent of
youtube drama is not yeah i think there
is a there will be a core audience that
does feel betrayed
um but i think the majority people are
there just for the popcorn yeah i mean
because like i remember like the most
recent drama i can remember happening
off the top of my head right now uh is
the one that involved pokemane and ninja
right oh yeah and like obviously that
got like a lot of views um
a lot of views when it came out and a
lot of people were discussing it but i
remember like my first initial reaction
to hearing about this drama that was
going on was
okay what the [ __ ] happened
it was so hard as a content creator i
was like trying to like [ __ ] piece
together who was mad at who who did
wrong to who how did it lead to this
situation and they were like like it
took philly d five minutes to explain it
and that's a lot for philly d
and like i'm just like one minute russia
is invading one minute for that yeah
five minutes of pokemon
it was like that i was like oh my god it
was like the majority of the video it
was crazy like i had i had like an
easier time understanding some of like
the world situation going on right now
and the world politics then then then
like how this drama started and the
evolution of this drama it was like so
surreal like trying to trying to figure
out why like what was going on right
because if me as a content creator who
knows the content creators within this
drama was like having trouble figuring
out because i wasn't there right at the
beginning yeah i can't imagine how a
general audience feels you know where
they're just feats where like it seems
like people are just seeing people talk
about this on their timeline and they
don't even like they don't even know
like that you get to a point where you
kind of are waiting for someone to tell
you who you should be angry at right or
who who's in the wrong and that's the
problem is that i feel 90 of drama is
not so much about like trying to uncover
the details and you know like gathering
the receipts and doing like a [ __ ]
criminal investigation into who started
it and who's the culprit who's the
victim it's literally just you see a
piece of drama like the pokemon in ninja
one right yeah and 90 of the audience
just goes
okay so who am i rooting for yeah give
me give me two people to root for give
me two people to fight for all right
it's ninja and pokeman all right uh well
i like that person better just from the
one thing i've heard about them so i'll
just root for them yeah because that's
not always the case but yeah a lot of it
is like that though you have to admit a
lot of it's like that it's basically
especially if you're not in that
community or don't give a [ __ ] about
that community yeah you know like you
know like if a bunch of like you know uh
[ __ ]
fashion youtubers right get into some
drama right like that's what they want
though yeah but that's what they write
right but like i'm not going to care
about the details all i'm going to care
about is okay so who are the two people
in question yeah and what is the general
consensus on these two people who are
fighting right like that's all it is to
me like other than that i don't give a
[ __ ] personally yeah yeah i i don't you
know even though it's good for business
i don't think a lot of these uh twitch
streamers try to get into this stuff
some of them some of them maybe do yeah
i know that i don't try to but i'm just
uh brash uh
with my words and also not very good at
coming like explaining my arguments on
the spot as we all know from trash taste
yeah sign up getting into these things a
lot of people aren't good at explaining
their arguments on the spot which i
think is where the problem stems from
right because you know i i would like to
think that we're all like very well
spoken and you know on the ball
when i want to be yeah you can be you
can be but like it's hard it's hard
where you have so many hours of content
around yourself just talking and just
not just trash taste but twitch
streamers as well and especially with
twitch streamers where they are
basically
on camera live in an audience like eight
hours a day plus you know there's going
to be a time where someone where you are
not as careful with your words where you
slip up a bit and that's just going to
happen you know it's uh
it's it's it it would happen to anyone
in the same situation you know
absolutely yeah yeah
you know you know something that uh
twitch streaming is uh made me feel a
lot more i feel like i
uh
i really feel a lot
more strong about the viewers who like
uh turn up like everyday to this [ __ ]
yeah i don't know why because like you
know when you're youtubing i see that
that [ __ ] uh who's a ninja guy who
comments on every video that guy without
mustache there's like there's like 500
of these channels right you're like
alright the same people can't whatever
but like on twitch it's like all right i
know a bunch of the names of people who
like turn up every single time there's
this uh person called like blue sky days
who every single stream gives me five
subs and i feel like they've made it
into a ritual
thank you i really appreciate it uh yeah
but like to me it's like
again going back to the hate stuff as
well it's like all right when i
think about getting sad about some
people not liking what you do or
whatever i'm like okay but like how much
more would it hurt me if i had to
explain to say that person who maybe
turns up all the time be like hey by the
way uh i'm quitting uh i don't like this
because some people said mean things
about me i feel like seeing that person
be like oh
you're gonna quit but i like watching
your stuff that would hurt me way more
than anything anyone could say oh yeah
of course of course connor's fell off
ratio you know whatever
that that you know that that nothing
yeah yeah of course of course i mean to
me like i i feel the same with like some
of my patrons because i like i have i
have patrons who have been fans of me
for like who have been watching me since
right since like you know [ __ ] 10 years
ago or something and they've like
they've been there since the start of
when i opened my patreon and they're
still with me to like to this day and
i'm just like that's that's [ __ ]
insane you know that's like you know
shout outs shout out to all you guys in
the patreon discord server because uh
it's like i i like having my patreon
discord server because it's just like a
very close-knit community and it's just
you know
it's it's it's nice having just familiar
faces that have just yeah it's like it
is it's just like stuck with you for
that long you know it it
it makes you feel what's the word not
validated but just happy that you kind
of do what you do you know yeah very
much i definitely feel that way as well
about like you know like youtuber
friends who were there since like the
very beginning right now yeah i have a
couple who were still around uh like you
know back when i had like [ __ ] less
than a thousand subs right i was doing
like gaming videos and [ __ ] and like i
still talk to a lot of them and like you
know if i would yeah again same thing
like if i were to just one day be like
yeah i kind of just [ __ ] hate this
you know people are [ __ ] on me blah
blah blah then you know i would it's
like betraying a family member yeah yeah
you know it's like they've been there
they've seen you know thick and thin of
me and being like nah dude you got this
and they've like believed in me the
entire time right yeah and then for me
to just be like
i can't take a bunch of people uh you
know giving me [ __ ] for saying that jude
zukaisen was okay i'm sorry i have to i
was considering him in the podcast
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's just okay that is offensive to
everything i i hold dear
the more you say it the more offensive
stop
i don't know how this is happening
am i supposed to rephrase it it was
average
it wasn't everything i'm not even
why do you think i don't want to start
these conversations these are the kind
of people that will say it's average and
then give love life a seven out of ten
you know what i mean it's like i can't
stand this oh i mean i i don't even want
to get into love like dude he's kidding
me [ __ ] that
we're very fortunate that uh you know on
youtube it's hard to have uh
not hard but it can be quite difficult
to be friends have a good friendship
with other youtubers for a long period
of time because of the nature of the job
definitely they're just uh you know
things change people get busy people
move people get on with their life do
different content fall off ratio all
that kind of stuff you know like the
work so you know very very lucky there
were some good friends and we've been
friends for very long time we all happen
to kind of be around the same kind of
sphere and do the same thing same time
it all kind of worked out very lucky and
i think yeah that's like another thing
as well is that like i think
you know like if we're going back to
like you know uh
[ __ ] helpful advice for like people
starting off right like another one that
i get often as well is that like oh what
do i do about like collabing and stuff
you know because like you know i feel
that's like the easiest way to grow out
your channel from an early stage and i'm
like yes in a sense if you do it right
um but you know
you shouldn't be like a channel with 200
subs and [ __ ] dming felix to like
collab with you right like that's you
know you got to know your boundaries and
stuff like that and also like another
piece of advice that i saw uh on twitter
the other day which i thought was very
true was that um you know i think a lot
of like youtubers have this like weird
especially those starting off have this
like weird misunderstanding that they
think everyone who collabs with them is
also a friend of theirs
and that is just unfortunately not true
a lot of people who just see it as
business who just want to do this
one-time thing or just to do this thing
to benefit
themselves but also you know the person
they're collabing with yeah and it's
it's almost unhealthy to see
a person who you collab with as just
your mate yeah
there's a very big difference between a
collaborator and an actual friend yeah
and i think like once you've like really
fully started to understand that at an
early stage and really gone and thought
to yourself okay who is actually my
friend
like someone who will hang out with me
when the cameras are not rolling
and who is someone that is just there
for the clout do you have a hard time
drawing that line like
no
no no
it's like you know i
i've done this for long enough now i
know i know just like being an adult
right you just kind of god forbid i have
to be an adult uh you know you kind of
learn just uh you you know you vibe with
people sometimes you don't vibe with
people sometimes someone is really like
you really love what they make and you
really like
how they go about it
and sometimes you hang out with them and
it just didn't it didn't click you know
yeah it's kind of weird the conversation
was a little like oh okay and other
times it's like holy [ __ ] like i i got
on so well with this person but then
maybe you feel that way and they don't
which is then this is an experience
thing we have to learn all right okay
even if i really like that person i like
hanging out with them i want to talk to
them again it's like all right you got
to be like normal about it
let's hang out next day let's do it you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah i spaced it out
yeah i don't know how we got to like
that uh i don't know how we became super
close but i i
because i remember there was definitely
a time when i was like yeah these guys
are cool but i don't want to like burden
them
i don't want to like text them too much
because i remember like when i met gom
we didn't really talk in between hanging
out it was kind of like we'd hang out
and then it was like a
thing i don't really know i mean you
sent me a [ __ ] email
i don't know how that worked i would
have put that right in the trash yeah
i mean i i'm the type of guy who really
connects with someone hanging out yeah
yeah i'm saying
like personally or physically you know
like i i need to touch your face you
should lick your sweat suck your gadgets
if you're a jojo
i didn't know what you were talking
about there
was sexually harassing
you are not a friend of mine until i
suck your dick
god is harvey wyatt
i i was i was i was going to mention i'm
the type of guy who might not talk so
much like online or wrong no no no no
like joking
does not sexually harass people
why it was just like like visual like
whiplash for me because i was trying to
make this poignant point and kind of
just goes god sucks dick he's like sweat
what did i say what did i say confirm
that was a weird time at the onsen
pretty sure i was told that's how you do
it
yeah because i remember we you know we
didn't message too much but we had a fun
time hanging out whenever we did hang
out in person and uh we just ended up
hanging more times in person and i guess
it just happened naturally right but i
mean yeah going off going from what you
said about you know being friends versus
collaborators i
like even me as someone who doesn't
collab too much i mean i barely clap at
all um but even me as a content creator
i can already i you know there are some
content creators who you enjoy their
content and you really respect the work
that they do but you know there are some
people that you just think yeah i
probably wouldn't get along with you
i love the work you do but i probably
would not get along with you and on the
opposite end there are also other people
who you don't like their content but
you're like maybe i can get along with
this guy
definitely seems seems like it seems
like a chill dude or something yeah
absolutely and you know it's that whole
thing of like separating the artist from
the odd right which is you know
way easier said than done in a lot of
cases yeah it's just tough
yeah i also it just feels like it's been
so long since i've been able to like
meet a lot of new content creators who
i've watched because of the past two
years you know because we've only been
able to meet people in japan right and i
feel like now normally like you get you
get a point every year where you get to
this opportunity to fly out to america
or fly out to somewhere to conventions
and actually meet fellow content
creators and i just feel like i've
forgotten what i've forgotten what that
feels like now yeah i've forgotten what
it feels like just to like just to have
that like first people just just have
like the first awkward meeting of just
oh hey i i watch your stuff yeah i like
what you do you know i mean like it's
like thanks
i miss just getting to speak english to
people
i just want to speak english to someone
do you remember the first time you met
someone online who you knew online but
you'd never like met in real life
do you remember what that feeling's like
oh
cause it's always like i i know like one
of the biggest things i first notice
it's always height always hype oh yeah
yeah they are never the height you
expect them to be oh yeah you know
that's that's that's true on my end as
well because every time someone meets me
the fir that's the first comment every
time it's either height or depending on
if you're a content creator who shows
their face or not it's also like how
they look as well yeah i definitely got
that when uh when i first met john super
eye patchwolf because you know he's in
almost all his videos he never shows his
face yeah so for the longest time people
didn't know what he looked like yeah and
then you know obviously when he first
blew up everyone was like all the
antitubers were like this guy's
content's [ __ ] amazing it's great i
would love to meet him and then when we
heard that he was coming to ax everyone
was like it was like a [ __ ] ax guest
he was like yo hype super high
vegetables coming to ax dude let's
[ __ ] go and then you you know you you
go to the gathering yeah and there's a
bunch of faces there that you think
might be super impactful right but you
don't know who right because you've
never seen his face yeah yeah and then
when you meet him finally
i remember the the first thing i said to
john i was like i'm sorry if this is
weird but you're like really hot
i mean he is he is
my god if i was a chick i would be head
over heels here's the sigma male yeah he
really is
and luckily he took it in like a good
way [ __ ] that [ __ ] jawline man
dude john john please that man
like dude he could break bricks with
that jaw yeah like it's it's crazy how
hot he is why aren't you more on camera
i know you need to show your face more
john you're a good-looking dude although
he did buy a dell computer that was
gonna oh yeah yeah
that was a great that was a great yeah
that was a good video
imagine a dell computer yeah yeah it
couldn't be me but like you know
when it comes to like looks as well but
also like physique and yeah as you said
like height you know like i get my
[ __ ] height pointed at all the
goddamn time and i'm like i never
thought that would be a weird thing yeah
did you ever meet up with people
online often like before youtube was
everything you ever used to do no not
really
yeah
because i feel like i got into i made
online friends because of youtube yeah
same yeah and like not not the other way
around um so it's
we're now with more especially during
the pandemic with more people making
friends online i'm sure a lot more
people are going to be experiencing this
experience but yeah but like yeah it was
it was like an alien experience to me
the first times the first time i did and
like it's still it's still weird you
never i never get used to meeting
someone who i know online and maybe
especially if they're like a content
creator you know and it feels so weird
now because i'm a content creator and
i've been on the other side of it and i
still like sometimes i just don't know
how to approach someone who i whoms i
know
that's it's so weird it's like it's that
feeling of meeting that content creator
that you've only seen in video yeah
and and the first thing that pops into
your mind is i've only ever seen you
behind a screen like like that mentality
never dies
it's so weird even though i'm also in
that same position now to that other
person it's so weird to say with the one
of my first thoughts is oh that's what
the back of their head looks like
i don't know why why is that because
because it's just not an angle you've
ever seen so it's just it's just weird
it's just so surreal seeing like just
just this angle i'm just like is that
that person and she's like oh wait no it
is that person oh okay
i kind of get one remember this uh i
should remember this really painful
[ __ ] cringe thing i did right right i
was at an ax party right yeah you know i
was chilling and you know it's where you
kind of bump into people that you
somewhat recognize or maybe you know
them you've searched them once you know
you go over and say hi and stuff
i was at this party and there was a
group of people like maybe like five
uh content creators influencers whatever
you wanna call yeah uh that i didn't
really know but there's one person who i
saw them and i was like oh i i know that
person i spoke to them in the uk so i
went over to go say hi right and i was
like oh hi and i see you how you doing
we like we hung out in the uk uh turns
out it wasn't that person i had mistaken
them and i thought it was then and i
[ __ ] you know this [ __ ] even that this
i'd never like been [ __ ] i hadn't
even drank that much it was like i had
two drinks just got that yeah yeah one
one or two drinks yeah and i'd even
though i like wasn't drunk at all i i
somehow sobered up even though i hadn't
i was still sober
um well yeah sorry about that um
i was like yeah i know you and stuff you
and she's like
it's not me and i'm like oh
i'm like because i you really look like
this person i really
really thought you were this person and
i was like okay i could have i could
have maybe i could have maybe died on
this sword and get out my phone be like
look this yeah you look really like this
but but no it wasn't and uh yeah it was
a really awkward thing where i was like
oh that's really embarrassing i'm really
sorry about that yeah you guys have a
good time yeah ignore me and then i
walked away really awkwardly like why
am i so cringe
i mean i'm sure uh have you have you
like met fans who have kind of been like
that as well like yeah i don't care i'm
i'm indifferent towards it but i know i
mean i guess that's how they feel right
yeah yeah yeah i guess when it's other
it was like five content creators it's
like great now they're all gonna think
i'm like this [ __ ] weirdo just
approaches people and goes are you this
person
it's me it's me look i think i have like
like i'm blind
and then when i got when i when i went
home whatever and i i i followed them so
was it another content creator or was it
it was another content okay
okay you happen to be in like the same
field and stuff as well and it was also
really awkward because uh you know i'm
sure they uh they they recently followed
me on twitter and i wonder if they
remember me going up to them like three
years ago yes if i ever meet them i'm
gonna ask them again if they remember my
my favorite interaction of that that's
kind of similar i was on the opposite
end though yeah it was uh in singapore
afa when i went with god
and uh there was this one moment
i couldn't i'll never [ __ ] figure i'm
sorry if you watch this show but uh some
like this guy i was walking with gone
and alan and sydney through the
convention hall yeah because i was on my
way to something and this dude just like
like spots me from across the hallway
right and he's like looking me dead in
the [ __ ] eyes right so i'm like oh he
clearly knows me right yeah i just kind
of you know just waved to him or
whatever and he came up to me and he was
like oh my god are you gigging
i remember that crap i was standing
right behind you and imagine me
imagine me this kid so [ __ ] excited
right saying calling me geek and me
having to go
no but he is
[ __ ]
the guy's just like yep
i don't even know how to feel about this
you know there was there was a split
second where i'm like this is a bit
right but like this is a joke
i'm just like should i be happy or a
friend i'm not sure but i kind of feel
both right now happy that obviously
someone you know someone recognized me
but someone knows me uh but i'm happy
that i was literally standing right here
and they go to joey and goes i love you
all joey hello
again at first i thought it was like
kind of just like a joke right being
like oh i'll just say it's joey hahaha
funny and you know i was waiting for him
to be like no i'm just kidding and then
actually turn towards god yeah but he at
the moment i kind of pointed to god and
he looked at god and just his smile just
dropped
like like he was like oh god i have made
a horrible mistake
i am so sorry to the both of you i mean
he knew he still knew me though but yeah
i guess he just mixed me and god's user
names up yeah you might have just said
yeah
yeah
yeah he was a nice kid so whatever but
it was one of the funniest interactions
i've seen
just experience have you ever had that
point where you you were talking to you
talked to a fan or something and they
said oh i loved when you did x video and
you think yourself i didn't do that
video i didn't do that video my favorite
my favorite is when they're like
sometimes
if we're like having more than a five
minute conversation
i didn't make that video but sometimes
they just like they just say this one
comment and they leave and i'm just like
i won't ruin their day yeah i won't ruin
that day i don't want to i don't want to
think they messed up yeah i don't care i
don't know
my favorite for those that i never have
the heart to tell them is when they're i
guess they're like really trying to sell
you on the point that they've been a fan
for a really long time and they're like
oh joey i [ __ ] love your stuff man
i've been watching you since 2010 man
like it's it's great i'm like alright
bye and then in the back of my head i'm
like i started in 2013. yeah
i don't i don't really have the heart i
was in high school
in 2010 so it would be scary if you knew
me back then jesus christ but i don't
have the heart to tell i don't want to
be that guy right to be like a fake fan
you know i don't want to do that to them
i don't know if i've told this story i
know i've told you guys this story i
don't know if i said on the podcast
right right it was the it was the meetup
i did at uh uh with book walker at ax
right where i just signed and took
pictures oh yeah yeah yeah yeah sydney
got like his stat yeah yeah yeah
interrupting right and the line was
pretty long i was very i was very happy
with myself i like wow people actually
want to come and hang out with yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um you know and this i don't know how
long the line took maybe like 30 minutes
i don't know how i don't know i think it
was capped i think we all capped it like
an hour right yeah yeah so yeah it was
like like that whatever 30 minutes and
uh i'm i'm doing that and uh like one
guy comes up to me and i'm like holy
[ __ ] like there's a there's a guy here
he's like sorry this is back in your
nightstand
it wasn't guys right yeah you know i i
appreciate it i was like oh thanks man
and so i'm like yo hi how you doing man
he's like i'm good i'm good i'm good and
then we take a photo and he's like yeah
man uh could you sign this goblin slayer
book i really like the work you did on
it and i was like
i was like coming in he's like are you
not the author for goblins and i was
like
no
i was like he was like oh but i thought
this was like a goblin slayer boost and
i was like
no
no this is i'm a youtuber
and i'm in my head i was like i was like
did this guy like look at the name yeah
i don't know who the author of goblin
slayer is but i'm guessing it doesn't
look like a connor sorry
his name is
maybe maybe a white guy from wales could
have you know written written a light
novel like damn this boy is very new
hong kong
that's the game holy [ __ ] it's so bad
for this kid because you know i didn't i
didn't care that he confused me but this
guy looks so embarrassed
and his face
he had never seen a face drop that fast
because we've taken the photo and [ __ ]
too on his phone and i'm like you can go
ahead and delete that i won't i won't be
mad yeah yeah
i signed this thing as well yeah i
signed his goblin slayer book and then
he tells me he loved my work on goblins
what was that a goblin or something
i didn't know what i did on goblin
slayer
i don't know if i should be an offender
because i i remember i remember like i
remember having this one conversation
once with a fan you know sometimes you
get into like pretty intense
conversation with fans about some of
your videos or something when you know
when you get when you have the time to
so i remember this one fan at like i
think it was like ax or one of the anime
conventions and we got we got into this
conversation about bleach right
and at this point i've said my takes
about bleach a lot whether on my videos
my first video was a bleach video in
other videos and um and podcasts or
turkeys just okay huh did you say it was
just okay i mean i i uh i've i've i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna open that box of
worms right now but like i remember
worms
of worms i'm not gonna open that kind of
worms right now but remember we're
having this like this [ __ ] intense
conversation about bleach and he kept
saying things like i remember when you
said this about the mundo arc and uh and
like this about tte kubo like like can
you like expand that because like i i
don't agree with this and we all like
having this full debate about this right
and i remember thinking
i don't remember saying this about
bleach but i might have said that about
bleach so i'm just going to entertain
the idea right right of this argument
he's like of this debate that he's
having about me and so we go into this
like 10 minute [ __ ] debate about
bleach right and then at the end i'm
just like yeah i finally understand your
fall of bleach video now and i'm just
like
that was john's video
and at that point i just i just i didn't
even have the heart to tell him because
i was like we've been talking about a
video that i didn't make for 10 [ __ ]
minutes
and having a fun debate about it
how did he not realize that your voice
and john's voice is like completely
different i how did i not realize that
he was talking about a video that i
didn't make because the thing is i've
talked so much [ __ ] about bleach now i'm
just like that sounds like something i
might have said i've talked a lot of
things about police i might have said
that if it wasn't it wasn't you arguing
europeans it was you agreeing with john
i was arguing john's opinion without me
even
step aside john i got this i got your
bag bro
i hope john appreciate it
no i've only showed that guy a lesson i
did i did uh john i'm fighting the good
fight john i'm fighting the [ __ ] good
fight he's got his boxing gloves on for
you man like he's fighting
oh
back
god it's also that thing where like i
have said so much stuff in my years of
being online yeah that i have forgotten
a good chunk of any jokes or anything
i've made and i've had those awkward
moments where someone will make a uh
we'll reference a video of mine yeah
from like five
four years ago and i'll be like
what did you say
like i said they said the thing and i
was like
why did
no the worst is when they ask you to say
it
being like i love this video that you
made can you say that one line and i was
like i know i say it uh no but it's when
you don't remember what they're talking
about when it's like a video from like
from a let's play from like six years
ago it's like say that one thing you
said in corpse party episode 42 and i
was like
uh
remind me how it goes again that's oddly
specific why would someone ask you that
i've had that
last year i mean i've made over a
thousand videos earlier i don't remember
every single one i made yeah it's it's
gotten like it's been extrapolated even
[ __ ] more with trash taste now oh
yeah well i will get comments or
i'll get like people i'm so excited to
have people bring up my opinion that i
totally forgot because i've had
conversations with people i've met here
um who obviously watched trash taste and
they were like i'm like remember and
they say to me remember when you said
this and i'm just like did i say that
i mean that kind of sounds like
something i said uh i don't remember
when i said it but uh like like the
bleach video i'm just going to assume
that you're right and i did say that so
let's just let's just entertain this
idea
basically if you meet me in a convention
and he said oh you said this what's your
opinion about it i'm probably just going
to entertain that idea regardless of
whether i said it or not
let's talk about that
i love conversions so much man this is
my like weekly reminder that i missed
conventions god i missed conventions so
much
i'm hoping out of hope that we will this
year be the year this year be the year
i'm all right i'm playing the rest of
the year we finally get to go to
convention let's find out yeah one day
this episode is sponsored by magic spoon
guys did you like cereal as a kid oh
yeah of course but don't you wish the
cereal grew up with you well introducing
magic spoon the perfect cereal for
adults
if i'm reading this correctly it's zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving and that's only 140 calories per
serving also keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free and low carb let me
try some now
what flavor
you got there i got the cocoa but right
here
it's got a nice crunch to it does it
remind you of your chocolate
it's so delicious you can better keep it
in your mouth it's actually really good
honestly magic spoon sent us a bunch of
cereal boxes to try out before and uh
apart from these ones me and sydney have
already finished all of them because
they are actually really really good i
actually i actually came to the office
this morning eating a bowl of these
frosted ones like honestly i'm going to
ask for more boxes to be sent here okay
that's that's that's not that's legit i
might take it off that is legit i
actually love this stuff so what are you
waiting for click the link down below to
grab a variety pack and try it today and
be sure to use promo code trash taste to
get five dollars off any order or go to
magicspoon.com slash trash taste and
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee i wish i had that my own life
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so click the link in the
description down below and use coupon
code trash taste for five dollars off or
go to magicspoon.com taste to save five
dollars a day get the cocoa flavor this
one actually slaps the frosted flavor is
also actually they're all really really
good
this one's my favorite yeah my favorite
is definitely the frosted one back to
the episode because we have i mean we
have a lot of things planned for this
year um that are you know out of outside
of japan um not spawning anything more
than just that but uh i'm hoping that we
i get to uh interact with people again
you know yeah that's that's that's the
biggest thing because convention i
missed the vibe of conventions you know
i didn't realize how much i missed it
until
until you couldn't go to it anymore
right i just i just missed that whole
convention vibe and just the the
positive you know the positive air and
the positive attitude and just you know
having fun for a weekend yeah i just
love that like you know like that the
ambience of a a convention hall of just
like the low murmur everywhere and it's
like exciting like everyone's just there
and excited and it's like you can feel
the i love the energy
yeah yeah it smells yeah yeah yeah i was
gonna i didn't i didn't think i would
miss the smell of stale sweats that you
that you like that you like smelling
like the
yourself i don't miss this [ __ ]
oh god i mean i i don't i miss it i
don't miss it i just miss that that
reminds me that i am at a convention and
this is this is the smell of a
convention when you walk into like a
clean room and you're like damn it man
it ain't that ax smell though
it ain't that hey it's too clean right
now too clean right definitely ain't the
gaming area
there's not enough precipitation in the
air there's not enough gamer
precipitation in the air i should miss
it so much
so especially when you get those like
you know it'll be like a few months or
even like a year later and you know
someone will say like they'll be like oh
i met connor x and x you're so nice and
i'm like
oh that makes my day mad even though
that might become a meme now someone
will be like i me i met connor at his
twitch chat he was so nice he called me
an idiot
i don't know i like being a dick online
with any person i'm like oh man i just
want to be nice to everyone i want i
want the opposite of that to be like i
met joey edicania was so nice i have
heard that
[Music]
i i think i've had that one time
actually someone's like oh connor was so
rude or something and i i'm like i don't
think i was i'm i really would be rude i
could scarcely be rude to myself let
alone like someone else i'm only rude to
my best mates yeah yeah that's basically
yeah yeah i mean sometimes you have to
you know if you're if you're being
ushered to somewhere
of course you have to be like sometimes
people will shout like oh jack i'll take
a picture and i'll be like well i can't
right now actually i have to have to go
there you know there's only one of me
and many people who you know some of
them thankfully
i hate being like no i can't take a
picture yeah i want to yeah yeah but uh
you know handlers and staff and whatnot
and one percent problems yeah yeah
living in a good life duty calls yeah
sometimes it's so hard people wanting to
take a photo with me god oh oh hello i
can't imagine ah what do i do with all
this i'm very
before before like you moved to japan
did you guys get called out by your
username more or by your real names did
anyone actually call you by like
always
or sebastian occasionally that remember
like yo sebastian remember that one time
we were in little tokyo right we were in
l.a
and we were shelling and then like we
were all about to like we finally were
done with our delicious uh i think i
think i didn't even have
uh japanese food i remember bibimbap
which is yeah yeah it was like the like
korean barbecue place right yeah so we
were leaving and it was good we were
chatting and some girls screamed like
sebastian and i was like
and i was really just embarrassed
because you guys were [ __ ] laughing
at me because they called me sebastian
because because it was it was that
moment of like we all turned around and
we were like oh i wonder which the bat
oh
connor's just like
this is like in the period where i was
trying my goddamn hardest to get away
from this like a reminder i mean yeah i
don't care if someone did it you can
call me sebastian
i don't give a [ __ ] i think for me the
i think it happened early on where like
of course people at first were calling
me anime man or whatever but like i
think i from really early on because too
many people were getting my usernames
wrong yeah and also the fact that i
didn't like my username what were they
calling you then if it was wrong oh
there was anime guy anime dude
it's not that hard
like every time i hang out like i was
next to joey i swear he would get like
anime man maybe only like seventy
percent of the time if that there's been
so many variations
but there but there were people who
would like get my actual name wrong as
well like i've been called john i've
been called the one that the one that i
couldn't [ __ ] believe and i
remembered to this day was adorable taco
thon some dude legit came up to me and
said hey josh
we're like 100 confidence 100 confidence
and i was like respect to that guy i was
like
i couldn't even like be you know i
couldn't be like it's it's joey because
i was actually just dumbfounded i'm like
you did not just [ __ ] call me that do
you not like josh do you have a vendetta
against strong oh nothing against josh
i've got mates called josh but i'm not
josh
why did the name josh specifically annoy
you more than john
i think it's because there's only ever
been that one guy who called me josh
watch it now next next day x or whatever
you're gonna be josh the anime guy i
understand you know like anime guy or
like anime dude or you know like
a different derivative of the word man
right because it's a pretty you know
it's a pretty generic name right the
anime is pretty [ __ ] easy well i i'd
like to think so actually like i think
i've gotten my like people have gotten
my name like my my my internet handle
yeah like wrong almost as much times if
they've got as they've got it right yeah
probably yeah uh because i mean i think
the biggest thing is obviously people
think my name's gig uk yeah yeah
they're like oh i love you i love it i
love i love uh i love your work gig uk
and i'm just like how long have you been
watching my stuff
i think i think youtube should implement
those uh pronunciation brackets that you
have on those like miriam dictionary
they need like the google translate like
say the words is my name that hard to
pronounce because i swear i've had so
many mispronounced
mispronunciations of my name and it
doesn't even piss me off i just find it
funny right yeah
i don't ever say anything i'm just like
whatever we'll just well at least yours
is just a mispronunciation mine is
literally just not the correct word
like there's only so many ways you can
like i didn't know you could pronounce
man as dude
or guy i i think it's just because i've
just like my entire life is a
mispronunciation of my name like
that's i'm just i'm just [ __ ] used to
it i i think the weirdest mispronounced
mispronunciation of my real name
actually yeah uh was actually when i was
in university so i remember in
university in freshers week especially
you meet a lot of new people very very
quickly okay yeah and obviously uh as
you all know gant is not a common name
at all right and you know so i've heard
like every [ __ ] mispronunciations of
my name by then and i remember like my
first day of uni i heard a new one right
so i go up to i go to a person and i say
hi my name's gant thinking they say
grant or you know garnet or one of like
something like that which which that
happens a lot garnet has happened
yeah yeah and and he goes and he goes
god
my name's god i'm like what
how did you how did you miss and hear
that how did you miss hear that no it's
it's it's gra it's not [ __ ] i almost
said
[ __ ] it
it's god it's been confirmed
it's canon it's gone it's gone because
how i explained it it's gone think of
hugh grant but swap the rna over yeah
that's gone and you know that's that's
how i like speed run um explaining my
name yeah and he was just like oh
god and i thinking i'm thinking my head
what a [ __ ] dumb ass how would you
hear god from ghant right that's that's
just like the anomaly he is the glitch
in the matrix and then literally like
two people later right i'm like
introduce myself and so like later in
the day i say hi my name's garn and the
second time god your name's god i'm like
what what the [ __ ] is what is going on
what is going on right now a very bold
move of a parent to name their kid god
so very bold name
you gotta have high high hopes for that
kid
and i remember somehow in freshers week
even though i did introduce myself to a
lot of people within that short time
frame like probably more than i have in
my life in that like one week or two
period three people thought my name was
god when i first introduced myself i i
i just i like
it it blew my [ __ ] mind i i just i
just love it when like people just
absolutely butcher my name in ways that
i just like wasn't expecting i think
that is like my favorite thing ever just
like having
now that i am like this public figure
where like you know even like my full
name is like public now right like yeah
oh my god i don't think there's no
there's been a there hasn't been a
single person who's pronounced my
surname correct really it's the first
time
yeah it's bizinger right but like my
favorite was the [ __ ] fccj uh panel
that we did
and the guy i think the guy called me
something like and here at the end of
the table is joey the anime bazinga
i was like first of all you forgot the
man
second of all uh
i didn't interview we should be you
should be the anime yeah the anime yeah
anime
joey the anime man
drop the guy
i think what i loved about that uh that
live stream with fccj is when he was
introducing my name and like i remember
he like introduced you he introduced
connor and then he i think he got to me
yeah i remember and this is and i could
see like i could see the [ __ ] word
processing in his mind and there was
like this brief pause before he said my
name and it was like it was like i i
remember like the chat going he's gonna
say grant
he's gonna pronounce it he's gonna
mispronounce it and i remember it was
just like a slight pause but that felt
like a [ __ ] that felt like an hour
you know
that felt like an entire death note
scene that [ __ ] pause man
you could have edited in like the aol
loadings
[Music]
three seconds
has anyone ever mispronounced sea dog or
gotten your internet and all wrong no
your surname is pretty difficult to
pronounce yeah but
also c dog is very easy as well yes i'm
really glad i chose that i mean we've
said this before right smart and easy
unintentionally i i you know
chose it to sound cool yeah doesn't
actually sound that cool
but now everyone just calls me connor so
that's easy yeah well that's what i like
about trash taste is that now we're just
known as joey garden corner yeah i i
have a request to anyone watching this
who will meet us in conventions uh i
know grant is a meme and it doesn't piss
me off when people uh call me grant um
but please call me guns because it will
get to a point where i literally will
not know if you just don't know who i am
or you're part of a you're a trash taste
viewer so please at least call me ghand
the first time before you start memeing
it up uh otherwise i would generally not
know like if if if you just are that
deep into the trash taste law or if you
just genuinely think my name's grant
like i generally genuinely won't be able
to tell you likewise with me um you know
josh is not my name uh john is all it is
it is if you call him josh now
everyone's gonna know that you watched
this episode of trash taste oh god
how come i'm not allowed to get away
with it what the [ __ ] yeah go outside
don't do this to me but do it to joey
yeah don't talk to me
don't do the exercise
it's not to me
people just spell my name incorrectly
that's all people say it wrong well i
mean there's only so many ways you can
[ __ ] pronounce connor yeah it's all
yeah yeah conair or maybe that's con air
conair con air i i think that's my
favorite movie yeah i think that's a
movie from a great movie great movie
my favorite nicholas cage it's an honor
to be confused with conor on her conair
yeah
that sounds like the cursive connor you
know
it's like if sebastian pronounces connor
maybe maybe
that's that's what you should be like if
someone at a convention stops you being
like hey sebastian they should be like
it's corn air i
never saw in my life until like i got on
the internet that you could spell conor
with an er
connor
connor
c-o-n-n yeah i mean i never saw that as
a friend of my school it was called
connor but we spelled c-o-n-n-a-h
connaught honor connor connor
the australian spelling for it because
there was also a place uh
near me that was called connor something
right um
but we spelt that one that is like a
very phonetic con isn't it
corner corner
yeah connor it was interesting because i
was like am i the weird no i've got the
normal i have them yours is the normal
one
i'm pretty sure i am the real one this
is all a joke you're all you're all
lying none of you are the real connor
what what is the uh
like who was the person who had the
weirdest name that you that you knew
personally
in your life what are you judges weird
like obscure or just okay would you
choose for me i knew a guy in my school
whose first name whose real name was
gameron
gammaron yeah not cameron
gameron with a g i kind of like that
that's i thought it was [ __ ] cool
that sounds cool but it's just like in
my head i was like
first of all where does that come from
and second of all was like their parents
handwriting so [ __ ] at the birth
certificate that the doctor was like oh
that's a it's an interesting that's an
interesting way to spell cameron i
there's a kid from another school i i
always was so jealous he they called to
that kid zeus
zeus was his first name [ __ ] yeah dude
and i was like i was like again the
problem with really [ __ ] badass names
is that if you don't live up to a badass
name it is looks pathetic like imagine
like you're like a kind of like super
shy person you're like yeah what's your
name oh it's zeus
it's like
you need to be larger than life if
you're called zeus right that's like
that's like in school when you had that
like one surname like you know i knew a
guy who's whose surname was champion
oh
and uh
unfortunately was it was he a champion
unfortunately no
wow he didn't quite live up to his songs
it was a surname though because if it
was your first time everyone's calling
you right right the parents must have
been confident they'd be like yeah you
better live up to this name or you're a
failure you are a literal champion
like the sperm bank got the highest
grade
sperm they're like nine foot guy went to
harvard 10 000 iq they're like this
guy's a zeus from 100
was it actually spelled like the gold
exact same like god uh that's so badass
and i remember because we i i threw
javelin against him and i beat him and i
was like
that's so ironic
i was like this is amazing i even i i
was like this is great i beat zeus i did
the time i didn't care though but now
i'm like i beat zeus with javelin you
know
one of my mates who used to live here in
japan uh australian guy uh his his real
full name was storm angus
that was like the most
australian ever that is the most badass
when he introduced himself as that i was
like no you're not that's that's just an
australian superhero name right
look it's still vegas
oh yeah [ __ ]
he just throws down like fosters
[Laughter]
oh my god
that's why i want to go to australia man
i i've never been to australia i just i
just really want to go sounds like a
[ __ ] it sounds like a laugh just just
oh yeah it's great
you'll meet like australia is that one
place where you're like i can't believe
people like this exist yeah like on
ironically i've always wondered what are
australian conventions like
uh okay so i've only i mean there isn't
really a lot uh i've been to
i've been to two different ones uh there
is supernova which is more like a comic
con yeah and then there is smash which
is the big anime con in sydney right um
the smash stand for anything yeah the
sydney mongrel anime show
good night yeah yeah so the first time i
went was in like 2013
14 something like that and there was
maybe like
3 000 people 4 000 people it was a tiny
convention um but the year that i went
uh before the pandemic where i was a
guest at there was like almost like 30
40 000 people so it's like clearly grown
yeah massively
um
in terms of but like i i honestly think
like in terms of like the actual like
vibe of the con and stuff like that i
don't really see it as that much
different to like a us con or any other
like english speaking convention because
it's like everyone can't experience yeah
it's just yeah yeah i mean not actual
cut switches yeah not actually we're not
actually like so we're not throwing
clothes on well australian [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i mean like even then though
it's uh i don't know it i i mean
obviously i i felt a little more at home
because you know i was talking to people
with the same accent yeah but um and you
know because like that was like my first
con ever i was like my home turf but um
yeah in terms like a con experience i
guess like yeah i didn't really see it
as that much more different to like a
standard like american con i guess like
the people i feel just like weebs in
general or like anime fans in general
like no matter where you are kind of
they kind of all give off like the same
vibe of like you know a lot of them are
just kind of like chill and down to
earth and just want to like chat with
you yeah i guess you know because like
in
australia like a lot like america is
like you know a lot of stranger
friendliness is still pretty prevalent
right yeah so it's like you know people
didn't really have at least not a lot of
people didn't really have problems you
know coming up to me and talking to me
and stuff like that just as like hey you
know joke or something like you know
stuff like so
yeah i mean you i mean you guys will
definitely [ __ ] have a great time if
we ever end up going to smash right now
or an australian convention it's just
you know every now and then you will
meet those like very stereotypical loud
aussies who you know are just like
[ __ ] yeah you know like that's that
level right but that's good that sounds
that sounds like a laugh yeah i feel
though those kinds of people you
wouldn't really find in a lot of like
anime cons you'll you'll see them at the
pub right but you know i very rarely
have i seen an anime fan dude it's my
convention do you love going to the pub
after that it's close yeah you just yeah
like kirito
downing like a stella you're like what's
going on i don't remember this part
it's like you know chicken like an
arsenal cosplay is like doing a shoei
yeah it's like that people who like to
drink
i didn't unfortunately see that but i
wish i did do a lot of people get drunk
at aussie conventions because that's a
big thing about british conventions way
more than like so much it is like it is
like all they do it's it's more than the
actual convention itself it's just
people are just like oh there's anime
here cool let's get a [ __ ] pint i
mean
it's hard to say at least in sydney i
don't think it's would be as much as in
the uk just because
like drinking or eating out in sydney is
really [ __ ] expensive like you know
like a pint of beer is like you know
[ __ ] ten dollars australian and like
a lot of like places in sydney right
like in the city um ten aussie dollars
or yeah like ten real dollars ten
dollars ten dollars for real currency
yeah ten dollars
so you know and i think to like a lot of
kids who come to these conventions you
know like ten dollars is a lot of money
right like that's cool that's ten
dollars you can spend on anime emoji at
the corner yeah of course um so i didn't
see as many drunk people as i thought
there was gonna be yeah but a lot of the
parents were getting drunk that's for
sure
you know they were like hey they've had
a hard day yeah
like an hour to get into the city and
being like all right kids have fun at
your japanese convention
daddy and i are gonna go over to the pub
and get shit-faced while we wait for you
yeah so like i'm taking care of the kids
yeah like in between like signings and
stuff you know i'd take a step outside
and you know you look over at the like
the terrace of some of these like pubs
like on the water and you know there's
just a lot of parents clearly just like
waiting for their kids just being like
another people
yeah all right
honestly i'd probably do the same uh
when i have kids you know yeah like yeah
because i i'm like an only child so i
never had this experience but i remember
like sydney talking about it all the
time where you know
your parents would just take you to
events and then you would just give all
the responsibility to the older sibling
to take care of the [ __ ] taking out
the younger siblings and just like
here's a bunch of money [ __ ] off have
fun you know yeah i definitely have that
that's the [ __ ]
maybe i can't remember really maybe i
was a little [ __ ] so yeah
i i think i've very rarely had
experiences like that because i think
like me and my sister didn't really like
share a lot of like the same like
interests when it like when we were
growing up i feel like as adults now
we're like starting to like share more
of like the same likes on things but
yeah i don't really like remember going
to like a lot of events with my sister
like we maybe went to like a few
concerts but did your parents ever take
you to an event that you just didn't
want to [ __ ] go to but you had to go
to because your parents were going oh
yeah yeah
football matches my dad used to drag me
in football matches he's going to love
this bit now he's like i didn't drag you
you wanted to go no he would bribe me
with chocolate he would he would be like
i'll get i'll buy you a like a galaxy
bar which is like this is chocolate in
the uk not like the small bars yeah like
the the this sized block one you know
we got some serious chocolate mileage
here he's like i'll buy it for you and
then i had to then this is the worst
part
my dad will laugh at this is that when i
was like eight
he would take me to like the pub before
yeah right right where where it was
literally like it's like a football club
right yeah yeah it's cheap it's dirty
it's absolutely rammed it stinks it's
like everyone is eating like pork
scratchings and downing like really
cheap pints i actually remember just
sitting there just like not
understanding anything
although that they would just ask me
sometimes stuff about football and i'd
be like yeah
wayne rooney yeah
she remember i never understood anything
right and uh one time i went to a match
and everton uh my my my dad's obsessed
with like everton family and stuff and i
remember they'd won because i was there
and my dad was like convinced that i was
the good luck charm yeah that's why we
won so i got dragged to more even though
i i told them i hate it i do not want to
go i i absolutely despise this because i
would just stand there i mean it was
cold and it was so loud and i just
wanted to play my game boy yeah and i
had to watch these people kick and i was
like why is it 90 minutes long
that's so long
so yeah to a child 90 minutes long
yeah and like i would always be like can
i get some like because i don't know why
i was a kid i just wanted to eat oh yeah
yeah i just wanted to eat and they would
sell those like stupidly long hot dogs
at these football events yeah i remember
one time i i had one and uh my dad let
me like just hold on to it for like two
seconds and someone bumped into me and i
dropped it all right and then i just i
was just so mortified and i remember i
think that ruined football for me right
no
i'm done
i don't even need a whole 20 videos this
guy didn't even buy me a new one he like
knocked me over and i was like what the
[ __ ] yeah but i was like eight i didn't
articulate all i remember was i was just
really sad that i dropped this hot dog
right right and you couldn't buy a new
one because it worked so my dad had just
given me like enough money to buy it and
it was like i couldn't you know i don't
know he'd like let me have it and i was
like oh my god no and then all the other
food was like oh it's really there's
like steak and kidney pies yeah right
from like this thing called pucker pies
in the uk that's so bad they're really
really bad right but no i remember i
remember that like yeah i sort of liked
it but just remember being like totally
confused and not really understanding it
and i never really liked football yeah
my brothers did though they liked going
uh and my older brother liked it a lot
but i just never liked it and i felt
like i was a failure to my dad because
he was like i just want you to like
sports why can't you like sports why
can't you be a normal person and like
sports i'm like the only kid in the uk
that didn't like football i was like why
why
i remember like because my my parents
were like really into like looking at
property right
and for the longest time i was like oh
we're gonna are we gonna move house like
you know i would get excited i'm like no
no it's like no we're just looking what
and i was like
we're literally window shopping houses
and they're like yeah and i was like two
or two like a 10 year old i was like
what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is like the most privileged
non-privileged thing i've ever heard
well because it's like you know because
my dad is like you know heavily into
like stocks and like investing
he's an investor i'm watching i'm
watching a home in the sun because it's
an investment yeah he was an investor
right and also like my parents used to
go a lot as well so that they could get
inspirations for like interior design
and stuff like that because you know my
dad loved doing like renovations into
the house and stuff so he would get a
lot of like good ideas from that right
it makes more sense um yeah but like you
know
to a 10 year old i don't know what the
[ __ ] like all that [ __ ] is right like
you would think if your parents came up
to you and said son we're gonna go check
out some houses today the first thing
you would think of as a ten-year-old is
yay we're moving right
and my sister who's like three years
younger than me was like oh we're moving
house that's so exciting yay so
naturally for the first couple of times
we'd go along with them right yeah until
we realized
we're not moving
we're just looking at we're him looking
at them i have a question actually this
just came out you can't answer it rip
unfortunately it's about brothers
so
how did
because you know obviously let's say
there's two two siblings or three
siblings in my house how was it decided
who gets which bedroom
ah
in your house that's a good question
well did you ever ask battle royale
squid game because i squid game i am the
middle son
and i got the tiniest room oh okay right
well i think for us we got lucky because
the house that i grew up in or i was
born in was like bought just
at the same time as they got that house
so i basically got first dibs right
because my sister wasn't born yet oh so
you got to choose i wasn't well i mean
no i wasn't like a three-year-old being
like father this room is a little larger
than the other one well you know what's
funny that's exactly what my parents
[ __ ] did really they asked me when i
was like two or whatever which room i
wanted when you were two i don't know
like
to at an age where i can i cannot
comprehend what i am doing
it's a big space either way right for a
kid yeah like this is fine this is great
i think i literally chose like the harry
potter club
and i'm like i'm like mum yeah don't
[ __ ] believe what what two or
three-year-old connor cho why would you
do that his mom comes out with the
contract is this this you that's your
name
did you sign my blog
what the [ __ ] is this i would never
choose it you know i would have never i
got the room which was right next to my
parents room because obviously i was the
firstborn child right yeah and then my
sister got the last room which just so
happened to be next to the toilet
right right so i remember she would
complain being like you know because i
think our rooms were pretty much the
same size like it might have been minor
differences but it didn't really matter
it was it was roughly the same size but
i remember my sister used to complain
being like you know well at least you're
not [ __ ] in a room where like every
time someone has to take a [ __ ] in the
middle of the night you get woken up by
it and i was like uh
yeah okay well that sounds like you but
also you're closest to the toilet so
yeah exactly that's what i said
if you have brothers and sisters or
whatever whatever how was it decided
which room was given to you can't relate
or were you all just shoved into one
room can't relate
well actually yeah when my when we were
like really really little my sister and
i like you know obviously just slept in
the same room in the same bed right and
then yeah it's probably maybe when i was
like i don't know six or seven that i
finally got to pick one of the rooms but
like i don't remember there being like a
ritualistic [ __ ] squid game of like
well wasn't it fight to the death
do you remember choosing the room no of
course not i don't know i asked my
parents later on last night i chose it
i'm like why would you listen to me why
i don't i am not in the right mind
make good decisions yeah i mean it was
probably massive to you when you chose
it you know yeah yeah it was tiny yeah
you could like there was no place to put
more than like a single bed not that i
would ever need more than a year yeah
even if i wanted bigger there's actually
no space to put it anywhere yeah and so
it was just like but of course you
talking about that right like you
obviously remember it different to your
parents right so i guarantee your
parents are gonna remember it and recall
it differently being like oh i
specifically remember connor [ __ ]
volunteering as tribute you know
they're like yes i will take the
smallest room for the family
going back to like weird events your
parents are taking you to so i remember
like i think the weirdest thing well not
the weirdest but the thing that sticks
out to my mind right now is my parents
or my mom once me once took me to a
meditation meet-up okay i think it was a
meditation meet-up okay so i think what
happened is so my mom's like buddhist so
you know as a buddhist this was before
like i became like a monk or a kid monk
or anything like that um
so you know
sometimes you uh you pray or you
meditate for good karma and all that
stuff so sometimes my mom would go to
like these buddhist meetups or these
meditation meets up uh what you do at
this meetup is you go there and you
meditate for about an hour in like
darkness right okay um with a bunch of
other people or a bunch of other people
right so like i was about seven years
old when this happened right so i think
like at that at that time like there was
no one to take care of me at home or
something i don't know why but my mom
was like
god you're coming with me uh we're gonna
meditate and shift i remember her
framing it in a way where we're just
gonna meditate for a little bit like
like like like five minutes something
that's what it was in my head right i
didn't know how long i would be sitting
still for yeah at this meet-up i thought
because i she told me how to meditate
and we do it for like 10 to like 15
minutes at most right that's what i
thought i was getting into so we get
there i remember like the guy the head
guy was just like hey thank you all for
coming um so we're going to be uh
sitting here i'm going to hit the gong
and uh we're going to turn off the
lights and we're going to just sit here
for an hour and after the hours on i'm
going to hit the gong again android game
everything lights up
and so i remember thinking
what the [ __ ]
i've got to sit here in silence for an
hour
what i was seven years old i could i
couldn't like sit still for five minutes
let alone let alone the [ __ ] hour
it's like solving the god
so i remember so i remember like sitting
down i'm like i'm like [ __ ] panicking
trying to figure out how the [ __ ] i am
going to sit here for an hour i look
over to my mom my mom's just like
already like [ __ ] in the zone yeah
she's she's already she's long gone
she's done it she's long gone she's in
another [ __ ] dimension right now
and so and so he hits and so hits the
gong luckily they have a clock in the
room so you can see how much time goes
past now what you're meant to do during
meditation is like you are meant to just
clear your mind right the point of an
hour is that it shouldn't feel like an
hour because to your mind it should be
as empty as possible so you shouldn't
really feel the passage of time or you
should feel it less than usual right
that's that's that's the entire like
zone you're supposed to get in with
meditation um so i remember all right i
remember thinking all right you got this
you've meditated for 15 minutes you can
do an hour um and i remember sitting
there and to me i'm like i think about
40 minutes has passed let me sneak over
at the clock i look over five minutes
has gone by i'm just like oh [ __ ] i
start [ __ ] sweating i look i look
around are you seeing the clock in the
dark huh it was like one of the glow in
the dark oh yeah with like uh with like
a luminescence that makes it even harder
not to look as a kid yeah
so i'm just like so i come up with this
five-head
five-head strategy right because i'm at
that point i was [ __ ] obsessed with
pokemon right so
yeah who wasn't so like i i remember
like
back in the day i had like recorded like
an entire season of pokemon and that was
like my entire my only entertainment so
i had like watched this vhs this
recording of pokemon like [ __ ] 10 20
times right
10 20 times so i think to myself how am
i going to get through an hour i got a
five hit idea what if i just watch
three episodes of pokemon in my mind
and just and if i watch three episodes
of pokemon in my mind an hour would have
passed right so it's like
i remember so i remember this [ __ ]
serial experiments
so i like i like escape into the castle
in my mind and i just started watching
i just started playing playing the
episodes of pokemon that i can remember
unfortunately i think some gaps were
missed off because i i remember like
watching in my mind yeah three episodes
looking at the clock and then and half
an hour had gone by so i'm just like
okay maybe time moves differently in my
mind
so i think i think i watched an entire
season of pokemon in my mind
your mind was just like all right
cutting out all the filler right now
only the important influence i think i
got through an entire [ __ ] season and
then i finally hear the gong and i'm
like i'm like thank [ __ ] and i remember
afterwards like
some of my mom's friends comes over to
her and be like well i'm like so
impressed with your son like how do you
sit there for an hour like my son can't
concentrate anything for five minutes
i'm like i'm so impressed with your son
and and i'm just like
they don't know i just got they don't
know i just watched pokemon for an hour
while you are drenching and sweating
they're like how does that just what
does that say again
oh ash was about to get to the indigo
league you and you stopped at the
[ __ ] good point man
where the [ __ ] did you do that that's
insane this man literally opened up his
third eye by reciting pokemon in his
head
anime companies hate this one trick
to letting you re-watch the anime
you want to recite pokemon that's the
real secret to like reaching
enlightenment you don't empty your mind
you just watch an entire season you just
watch one piece in your mind and you
just reach enlightenment could you do
that now i could not do that now
i could watch a show and then couldn't
do that immediately after that well
because that was back in the day when
you were a kid and you had like that one
thing that you watched over and over oh
yeah yeah yeah you could just like
recite it like i remember i could
probably like recite the entire movie of
toy story or something in my mind
because like i've watched it so many
times
i have some movies like that too i could
probably recite the entirety of pulp
fiction that's because i've seen it so
many [ __ ] times but right now
three and a half hour movie let's go if
you need to meditate for that long
when i need to meditate i'm just like
i was like say what again say what again
i dare you i'm double d [ __ ]
you know what they call quarter pound
with cheese in france
did you never have that on the kids as a
kid just like some a game or something
that you played so many times that you
could just like recite it from memory
no no never not recite here i've
probably played stuff a bunch but never
saying i could recite
from memory but are you the kind of
person who remembers song lyrics easily
no not at all i i actually cannot
remember song lyrics without looking at
the sheet right and even then it's like
it'll last like a day yeah because it's
really interesting there's like there's
two types of people where there's like
there's ones who are like you can listen
to a song once and you just like
miraculously just remember how the
lyrics go and then there are people who
are just like i could listen to this
song 50 times
and it's like i'll recognize the lyrics
if someone tells me
but i can't recite it okay so i had just
like i had this like realization the
other day um because you know i've
obviously i've obviously given connor a
lot of [ __ ] for like hearing the beeps
and the boobs yeah um and then i just
had this realization that
i think i listen to this i think i
listen to music like beeps and boobs as
well right because
okay like lyrics mean nothing to me like
like it's it's so it's so weird yeah
it's so weird right where i i listen to
a song and
if lyrics aren't there right i i feel
like something's missing because i do
think lyrics need is a part of the song
but to me lyrics are almost like another
instrument instrument to me it's it's so
weird it's so weird where where like i
don't listen to what they're saying and
even like even if
you can take a song that i love and you
lay the lyrics out in front of me and
i'm just like i've never heard this song
in my life like what is what is this
song well i would argue that the best
artists and the best singers and the
best bands i guess can yeah as you said
use their voice as an instrument
but then if you want to read into the
lyrics the lyrics are also profound
where unfortunately
very few artists can do that right where
it's either like you either concentrate
fully on the lyrics to be like here's a
deep poetic meaning behind understanding
this are you saying the voice is a part
of the song is that what you're saying
yeah yeah well yeah no [ __ ]
it's like another but but you know there
are a lot of artists who don't see it
that way and they just like it's like
it also depends on how the songs mix but
like some artists you hear and it's just
like oh
i wish i could hear the instruments
because it's just being drowned out by
the singing
but like have you ever like
properly listened to the lyrics of a
song and it's like change the way you
think about a song because you probably
actually read into it
like the the new weekend album is really
good but like if you just actually
listen to what you're saying it's
depressing as [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah so
that rarely ever you're like vibing
you're like dude this song is so good
and he's like i'm [ __ ] depressed and
[ __ ] is going wrong and it's like yeah
[ __ ] this is so good
wait what do you say
you
yeah i can't i can't even get to that
moment because it like it it's really
weird but like sometimes if there's like
a disconnect between how the song makes
me feel versus what the lyrics are
saying i always like go i always go
towards what the song makes me feel yeah
yeah and and it's it's so it's so weird
because i don't know how much of this is
[ __ ] well actually
yeah it's that that's it i hear the
beeps in the boobs the beeps and the
boobs make me feel something and that's
what i feel towards the song that i
hardly ever listen to lyrics at all
because it never changes how i feel
towards the song it's it's so weird
you guys are literally that type of
people who would make a [ __ ] art
buzzfeed article being like top 10 songs
that have a dark meaning
engineering
i don't know you you i hear the [ __ ]
the music it comes in and it just comes
in like a
like a like a like a i don't know like a
[ __ ] graph in my head it comes out
the thing is i get that i totally get
that but i feel it like i i do have
emotions towards it yeah of course but i
don't give a [ __ ] what he's talking
about right i'm like i'm just in taking
the noise and the noisy that makes me
feel something or it doesn't yeah which
is why i think for a lot of songs where
there is like a stark contrast between
how the song makes you feel versus how
the lyrics make you feel yeah is what is
like a bigger whiplash for people like
you guys right where it's like oh what
the hell live i don't know how i want to
preface live it is different there
definitely is a lot more to it whenever
yeah yeah yeah
recorded album yeah i feel like that's
why i find it so easy to you know listen
to a lot of japanese music or a lot of
like music in a language that i don't
understand yeah because it's they're
probably you know i i have no idea what
the lyrics they are spitting most of the
time but you know this part of me is
like i feel i feel the emotion
yeah i i feel the emotion that they're
singing right now oh yeah i kind of get
it even though i probably don't get it i
feel like i get it you know i can't tell
you like like i'd say 90 of anime
openings the lyrics are depressing as
[ __ ]
yeah but but like just weaves that are
kind of like man
which is you know fine it's it's cool
that's what i find really interesting
though about people who can do that
right and it's like you know it's the
reason why i feel that in and of itself
like that discovery of like when people
find out this really like bright and
like colorful and like very positive
sounding song actually has a really
[ __ ] dark meaning and then you know
and it's that realization of like oh
[ __ ] i just got played
because i wasn't listening to the lyrics
right like that's why i'm like because
we've we like had this idea to do a
music three by three for like ages and
i've like loki actually been [ __ ]
myself
why because like
one of the things one of the mediums i
find hardest to [ __ ] explain
is music because i literally are just
like um i mean this song this sounds
good this this song made me feel things
um and i just really like it um and and
people are like oh did you know the
meaning of that song i'm like i have no
idea the meaning of that song yeah yeah
but it made me feel things yeah things
welcome to the beeps and the boobs
ladies
i thought you were on my team
i feel betrayed welcome to the beeps and
boots oh glass glass vehicle and i feel
absolutely betrayed
god dammit the music episode would just
be joey talking for two hours yeah right
and then
i like this one yeah
that's why i almost don't want to do it
because i think i'd probably just make a
video on my own you're gonna carry the
episode yeah exactly which might be the
shortest trash days episode of all time
yeah probably like 40 minutes in my life
and that's it yeah all right thanks for
joining us
do you have an example of like a song
where the lyrics um where you where the
where you found more like reading into
the lyrics and the deeper meaning of
that song as opposed to just listening
to you know the initial beats the beeps
and the boobs the beeps and the boobs i
mean like like i'll go into pink floyd
the wall
oh yes
but also like yeah i think there's like
a lot of like artists that you know
again it's like it's it's that
brilliance of you know using the lead
singer as just like an instrument where
it's like if you're not listening to the
lyrics or anything like that it still
sounds great and it's still like sticky
in your head but then you but then one
day you're like you know i've listened
to this song like three or four times
but i never actually read the lyrics let
me read into the lyrics and then you
read into it you know a lot of it's very
like poetic and you know it completely
changes the way you view that song like
you know [ __ ] like great like you
know [ __ ] you know you know turning
japanese you know that song yeah no
turning japanese i think i'm doing it
yeah i know that song's about
masturbation oh yeah but no one knows it
because no one [ __ ] reads into the
lyrics they just see they just hear that
and i was like oh yeah i love that song
this is what turning japanese is about
yeah it's about masturbation i i've
never heard of these songs well like how
pumped up kicks is about school
shootings right i know that one i know
like when people first discovered that
they were like oh my god i've been
[ __ ] debated right but it's catchy as
[ __ ] it's catchy as [ __ ] it's crazy it's
a jam of a song right it's like i don't
know i find that to be like as someone
who also writes music that is so much
[ __ ] harder than it looks yeah i know
i can imagine and i feel bad that i
don't or i have the inability to
appreciate it because like but i feel
that's fine because like i feel with
those kinds of songs they're taking into
account how it sounds first
and then they think about the meaning
afterwards right yeah i think the only
exception is with like rap music you
know where it is just like basically
just lyrical poems to a beat right so
that's where i actually have more of an
understanding or like or like an image
in my head of oh man these lyrics go
[ __ ] hard but right yeah they do
listen to the lyrics yeah but try it
right yeah but like most of the times i
actually see the lyric sheets and it
almost like it almost like transforms it
that to a point where i don't even
recognize the song anymore it's always
like separate from the song itself it's
so weird if someone can explain this to
me like i'm like super curious
because i've just i i think i just i i'm
incapable of
like getting the meaning of lyrics as
i'm listening to the song at the same
time i recognize anything to do with the
fact that i'm the only musical trained
one out of the three of us
probably you probably appreciate it more
yeah maybe to me it's all noise right i
like it
yeah but it's noise i mean i i i can
play musical instruments but i've never
been like professionally trained right
right you know i think that's just what
it is right like i feel it's just
because you've been trained to listen to
music in a different way yeah that you
can just perceive these smaller points
that other people would just perceive as
just the beeps and the boobs right i
mean to me like it's like it's like
people who you know go to a gallery and
look at art right it's like you've
clearly just been like a lot of them
have just been trained to look at this
thing in a completely different way that
you otherwise would have a very hard
time grasping right like you know you go
to an art gallery with an art critic and
they'd be like yes i love the the flow
and the the texture and the feelings
that i get from it it's making me feel
this way and the average person looking
to be like oh yeah i like the color red
as well you know like
it's just i think it's just based on how
you're trained yeah like like to me like
you know i can play musical instruments
and um stuff like that but i've never
like
i've i've never thought i was i've never
like studied music theory or anything
like that so like when i like wrote
songs before it was more like
c major sound nice or something or
something like that i don't like you
know her her chords sound nice that was
just like my process you know
musically trained
musically trained
god damn but yeah at this rate i don't
know if we'll ever actually end up doing
a music three by three i'm down i just
gotta think of nine albums i like uh
right now i can are we doing albums or
artists that's the question i think i do
artists artists okay there's cause like
four five yeah
four four five like that i feel like i
could strongly say i've listened to
everything i like everything a lot of
others i'm like i like this one album
you know like arctic monkeys i like a
lot but like not every album you know
right right and i get it you want to be
experimental do your thing but i don't
know how i can sit there and be like
this is one of my favorite artists by
the way this one album [ __ ] i don't like
yeah well no i think i i think that's a
valentine's day
i mean i mean like
a lot of my favorite artists have a [ __ ]
album or two
like i don't know if i'm a anomaly in
this as well but i don't normally listen
to albums as a whole right
songs yeah yeah yeah normally yeah yeah
like
i'm like shooting myself finding like
think of nine albums because i'm like
how many like four albums have i [ __ ]
listened to it we'll do it eventually
yeah we'll do it eventually i got to
figure out how to like talk about music
first yeah you guys deal with that
and then when you guys already come back
and then we can do it and i'm like i
feel like he was trying to say something
with this song i could feel it i don't
know what it was exactly but i feel like
i like these words in this song he said
he felt it coming many times and i
believe he did feel it coming oh i was
definitely coming as well
oh my god
but anyway that's been this week's trash
tastes oh my gosh these patrons though
oh do they listen to lyrics i don't know
but they listen to us on spotify oh they
definitely do listen to us on spotify
and they also support us on patreon you
can do the same as well by going over to
our patreon patreon.com
also what's that they listen to trash
taste which is all lyrics it's all it's
all lyrics nothing but lyrics everyone
knows trash taste bars
nothing but bars for two and a half
hours but uh yeah if you like to support
the show go to our patreon also follow
us on twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify but uh yeah
music three by three coming eventually
when these boys are ready
when i'm ready to talk about music in
the meantime thanks for watching guys
and we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you